AL DYKSTRA: Oh, my gosh.
NARRATOR: Near the site where
Lieutenant Colonel Benjamin
Pritchard and a group
of Union soldiers
arrested Confederate President
Jefferson Davis in 1865,
Al Dykstra and metal
detection expert
Gary Drayton have
just made what could
be an important discovery.
GARY DRAYTON: Yep.
Now we're talking,
Civil War find.
AL DYKSTRA: That is.
BRAD RICHARD: Find something?
GARY DRAYTON: Yep.
Bit of Civil War.
BRAD RICHARD: No way.
KEVIN DYKSTRA: What
did you guys find?
Oh, I don't know if
I'm ready for this.
Probably part of, like, a
canister shot or a slug shot--
KEVIN DYKSTRA: Oh,
yeah, shrapnel.
Yeah.
KEVIN DYKSTRA: Wow.
GARY DRAYTON: Normally,
when you find these
and it was part of,
like, a larger shot--
Like artillery?
GARY DRAYTON: Yeah, normally
you can see where it was all
packed against each
other and you'll see,
like, little slopes on them.
It's got a flat side on it.
GARY DRAYTON: Yeah.
If it's got flat
on it, that means
it was part of a larger shot.
KEVIN DYKSTRA: Wow.
BRAD RICHARD: Nice work.
So I wouldn't be
surprised to find a lot
more of these in this area.
BRAD RICHARD: I think there was
a lot of soldiers on both sides
that really wanted
that gold, and I
think what we're
seeing is evidence
of how badly they wanted it.
NARRATOR: Just before dawn on
May 10, 1865, as a detachment
of the 4th Michigan Cavalry
began their approach
to Jefferson Davis's
campsite from the southeast,
another Union detachment from
the 1st Wisconsin Cavalry
was also advancing
from the north.
A firefight ensued.
And two members of the
4th Michigan Cavalry
were killed before the
regiment ultimately made
the arrest of Jefferson Davis.
But although the
incident was later
recorded as an unfortunate
case of friendly fire,
there are those who believe that
Benjamin Pritchard had ordered
his men to shoot anyone who
tried to thwart his efforts
to capture Davis, and with him,
seize the Confederate Treasury,
even if it meant
firing on Union troops.
Have Kevin Dykstra and his
team just found evidence
that the so-called
friendly fire incident also
involved heavy artillery,
suggesting that Pritchard would
stop at nothing
in order to arrest
Davis and capture a fortune in
Confederate gold and silver?
[beeping]
GARY DRAYTON: See
how nice that sounds?
Let the big fella in
there and dig it up.
Can I take this one?
Yeah, of course.
[beeping]
GARY DRAYTON: It's a coin.
And it's an oldie.
BRAD RICHARD: From
the Civil War?
GARY DRAYTON: Oh, yeah.
You can see the stars going all
the way around the edges of it.
That is a silver
Confederate coin.
[laughter]
Woo!
Wow.
NARRATOR: A silver
Confederate coin?
Could Kevin Dykstra and his
team have actually found
physical evidence that a fortune
in stolen Confederate gold
and silver was buried
here and then retrieved
more than 150 years ago?
To come out here and find
a Confederate coin where we
think that those wagons were--
Your research is proving true.
Those wagons were carrying
60 kegs of silver coins.
When they dumped them in the
ground, they got most of them
when they dug them back up,
but we found one they missed.
NARRATOR: For Kevin Dykstra,
finding physical evidence
that supports his theory that
millions in Confederate gold
made its way from a
burial pit in Georgia
to a boxcar that lies somewhere
at the bottom of Lake Michigan
has given him and his team
renewed confidence that they
are on the right path.
But a crucial question remains.
How did six wagon loads of
gold, silver, and jewels
travel all the way to
Michigan without detection?